uh james bond no time to die it's time
it's time
it's time to die it's time to yeah what
do you think about that
uh
rare manicure like what was the point of
him being the worst villain ever really
so [ __ ] you're not seeing it you're not
born man you're born
doesn't go to the cinemas in japan i
don't i don't mean i don't go to the
cinemas in general unless there's a film
i really really really want to see yeah
psycho pass like
maybe
maybe you know if there is a
if akira was in cinemas i'd go see a kid
oh [ __ ] yeah yeah because i haven't seen
it in cinemas and i think that's it's
one film that you would appreciate way
more on the big screen yeah like doom
yeah
why didn't you get watching cinemas i
don't understand i just i was in cinemas
for like three months yeah yeah i don't
know i i actually would i actually was
just like oh is it in cinemas like last
week googled it wasn't so i was like
[ __ ] it i guess i'll just watch it
just
sometimes i just get lazy you know
because for three months huh
yeah yeah
[Music]
when's the last time you watched anime
connor
oh recently
yeah okay count right okay yeah
that doesn't count i don't know
what was the last time you watched anime
that you went paid to watch
you know sometimes you just have
something that's not on the top of your
priority list and then it just slips and
then you miss your opportunity
unfortunately yeah i've said this a
billion times but i just like the
theater experience it's just a good the
right way to enjoy a movie well i mean
the matrix might have been a bit near
but the you know in the cinema imax it's
the first time i've seen a matrix movie
in a cinema because it came out in 1999
i was nine
and uh so it was pretty cool watching
like a matrix movie the way it was
supposed to be sort of yeah the imax was
incredible
uh what are you a marvel guy at all
yeah i want to see the new spider-man i
absolutely love spider-man 2. it's like
one of my favorites probably my favorite
which spider-man 2
the original one the original one okay
alfred molina
yeah it's a cracker yeah i watched dark
waters last week what's that exactly
like where'd you find time to watch all
these films yeah don't just get an
evening you should go and i'll stream
afterwards
are you gonna watch spider-man uh well
when it comes out for some reason japan
it comes out like three weeks after the
rest of the world yeah so the matrix
came out here like before anywhere else
because there's like a seed in japan
maybe that's why but like every film in
japan comes out so late it's so nice
it's either too early or too late yeah
because i'm too early
too early by the time it comes out the
spoiler lift is going to be gone on like
online right yeah there's a two week
spoiler
period where no one's about to allow to
spoil it and by the time that's gone the
film still hasn't come out in japan so
i'm probably going to know what happens
in it before i even go see this i just
don't yeah i haven't read anything about
it i don't know i don't know
don't [ __ ] say anything you did give
me you support inception what what
ken did that don't worry give me you
give me fifty dollars i won't tell you
what happened you [ __ ] off
black movie blackmail spoiler blackman
spoiler black man yeah i wish a lot of
a good amount of the western releases in
japan i don't even like
look what it's about i just go up and
just watch it
sometimes to poor
rates of success i'd say this was a good
movie it's just mark ruffalo being like
for like two hours this project sounds
amazing
what is the film about mark ruffalo
it's like mark ruffalo just like being a
japanese business uh
about how like dupont a chemical company
just poisoned everyone in the world
basically sick that sounds like a
problem and and how like they did it for
like four years and mark ruffalo is like
the lawyer that finds out and like
shoots them and stuff so it's based off
a true story yeah it's like still
ongoing as well oh wow yeah
the film or the uh oh the real life
yeah it's like poison like everyone in
the world oh wow what the [ __ ] yeah
everyone's been poisoned by this one
chemical that they were dumping yeah
it's pretty sketchy now now it's like
one of the un's like priorities it's
like bend this chemical it's pretty good
movie though it's pretty good
really you're really selling ourselves
you're really [ __ ] paranoid to drink
any water yeah
really selling a slaughter thank you i
don't know it's just nothing
can't fix right yeah
an activated charcoal can't fix no it's
fine it's a good movie uh mark ruffalo i
he's all right i think he's not like the
best actor on earth but he's just kind
of okay in every film he's pretty yeah
he's pretty good
he's not like amazing i'm never
compelled by his performance yeah what
have i seen him in that's not marvel
collateral tom cruise
yeah he plays like an underwhelming
detective he thinks
he's really good at playing like a wimpy
character yeah which i don't know
mark ruffalo's agent he's got a [ __ ]
role ready
he's dying he's too cool that character
because he's kind of like a pushover in
the film but it kind of
plays to his uh strengths because then
he kind of gets over it and it develops
character development yeah poor old mark
ruffalo he's watching this in a room in
l.a like [ __ ] hey he's [ __ ] a
billionaire he doesn't need my [ __ ]
billionaire this isn't my [ __ ]
sympathy yeah because the i notice when
the movie starts it's like a film by
mark ruffalo corp or something it's like
it's his movie company mark oh is it
yeah so it's his movie there's something
so funny about that i don't know why i'm
just having an actor star in their own
film i'm always like well we're going to
get a conor kaluan movie
what
about what me [ __ ] doing a crane game
for two hours
uncut
the the quest for curious george yeah
the director's cut
i have no interest in making a film
though if i gave you a hundred million
dollars what would you make more crane
game videos
the biggest crank i spent a hundred
thousand dollars
i make uh
the shittest squid game possible for
three million dollars
mr b spent three minutes just like money
laundering three million dollars just
like a cardboard set
i would have been actually in some ways
i think i would that would have been
almost as funny
right
version of squid game yeah someone must
have done that
probably did you see those uh that one
hamster channel they got like a lot of
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah yeah squid game
hamster squidward making these hamsters
drop from like massive like gods and
there's like spikes and stuff jesus is
awful
i i watched the video and it was like
it's honestly not that bad like i don't
know there was some bits where i was
like yeah that that hamster could have
been impaled
uh
what if what if the uh hamsters were
just cg'ed in yeah what if the support
of this
one of them was voiced by gun
cgi equivalent unfortunately i think
there's one thing that you cannot even
remotely try and get away with and that
is anything with you that comes close to
abusing animals yeah that's like the one
thing that you just can't get away with
i mean right so yeah
i think that's that hamster video was
just a bit
but yikes yeah they're definitely better
ways to do what i feel but it's a bit
it's a shame as well because that
channel like i i've been because that
[ __ ] channel comes with my
recommended all the time because he like
makes little miniature like onsens and
like massage parlors and like little
sets for his hamsters like kind of play
around yeah there's like a little mini
waterboarding scene as well
yeah but it's like it's really cute and
it's like you know
and then for some reason he was just
like yeah i'm just gonna
make them fight to the death he would
make hamsters drop right from like here
onto the floor
it's not deadly but it's like why would
you make it it's not deadly but i'm sure
you know one bad fall and it could hurt
people what's this cool hamster squid
game yeah yeah if you look up here
i think it's a hamster i'm done with
squid game it was it's a right tv show
all right let's never speak because
we've done it better christopher's done
about it octopus game is a squid game
it's good it's good yeah that's good
what would you change just got it you
just don't want to hear about it ever
again
it's been done a lot right you know it
has been awesome squid gaming yeah let's
let's never think you you think i got
too popular
i i think i i just
you know i i get a bit annoyed with
things that everyone obsesses over i
remember well i remember obviously when
frozen came out right and yeah
you might have been there but like it
was like everyone got so obsessed with
every [ __ ] store you go down let's
let it go and i'm like i think you're
the ones
that song was like every day like 400
times i want to kill someone and i felt
like that about squid game a little bit
it was a good show it was good i enjoyed
it a lot but like when you just hear
about something you're bombarded by
something so much
japan's so good at that though it's like
when there's like one like viral like
song that's high in the charts like
[ __ ] like you know any song any it
could be anything it's just like every
second store is [ __ ] blasting it my
favorite thing is when japanese stores
play obscenely inappropriate songs in
english
in like a children's daycare because
they don't know what any of the words
mean
they're like rap that's like super like
[ __ ] yeah i i remember i went to this
toy store in shibuya once they were
playing whap
like loud on the speakers i was like ah
they were playing whap in one of the
supermarkets i go to as well
and i was like the uncensored version i
was like whoa i'm like there's like
there's like all these like toys
everywhere and i'm just like
saying what kind of wholesome about it
family restaurant they're playing 50
cents in the club
and i was like eating like a ham
sandwich or something just listening to
him
[Laughter]
a little bit out there like chris came
in put put the song on for chris he
loves the song the song that defines me
[Music]
restaurant oh my god